also new tonight changes on the way to a
busy area near downtown Las Vegas
Governor sisilak along with city leaders
and representatives from the White House
announcing some improvements to this
four-mile stretch of Stewart Avenue now
the money to do it actually comes from
the president's infrastructure Bill the
governor and White House infrastructure
coordinator noting how this benefits the
area in many ways once it provides you
know some equity in terms of how the
infrastructure money is being spent
provides more safety and comfort for
this area this is a hot spot area we're
going to have 700 trees planted we have
bike Lanes there's already been 900
million dollars that has been sent from
President Biden to Nevada four roads and
bridges and airports and ports and
waterways and there have been a number
of projects that have actually already
been funded so this isn't the first
project this is like the eighth in a
reasonably short period of time so
everybody is going to benefit from this
long-term plan out there other projects
announced so far are tens of millions of
dollars worth of improvements to Harry
Reid International Airport as well